so how many companies have gone through
alchemist accelerator
and what is your standard deal do you
have 100k for six percent or
25k for five percent what's the deal and
how many have gone through it in the
last eight years
300 have gone through um uh and
our standard deal is 36 000 us dollars
for
five percent of equity that is
negotiable
so we do there is a range and
um uh we do it we do cater the
package depending upon the company got
it which would be an applied seven
hundred thousand dollar evaluation
uh which is roughly half of what we get
and this you know
a third of what y combinator asked for
so you do get people saying hey that's a
low valuation
how do you react when a founder says i
think my company's worth more than
750 000 or 700 000 what is your
response to that well so the reality is
is that
the um the valuation the cash is really
everybody who understands alchemist
knows that no one does it for the cash
so
if you calculate the valuation that way
i understand how you're looking at it
um we actually try to structure this so
that it doesn't hurt the founder from it
come from a fundraising perspective
the re the cash um
it's a little bit complicated to go into
but we structure the
financing so that it's not going to be
at a it's not going to trigger things
that are going to lower the valuation of
the company
so you put the 36k in at the whatever
the last round was
then get the balancing different equity
in
options or warrants or something that's
essentially it yeah
or common shares yeah yeah um
that's effectively it and would you do
that you have to negotiate that every
time with every company
no it's it's it's fairly standard like
the doc but but but we do
but i mean we do negotiate with every
company so we're not
yeah so yeah we do so you know that's
gonna be brutal like
every company thinks that they're worth
10 million dollars
and they're not in many cases in most
cases in this case
and then how do you deal with the
fairness of like hey they're all in the
same cohort and one says well i got this
deal and i got this deal
doesn't because i have the same issue in
arms where everybody wants to get a
unique deal and everybody thinks that
they're
you know the greatest thing ever and the
other companies are not so
how do you deal with that i'm curious
it's a conversation to be honest so i
i think what it's not that we have any
heart so the first thing is that we like
that because
we do want the founders to know that
it's not cookie cutter like we're
actually we treat each
team and this is why we're not y
combinator we're not you know we're not
admitting
200 companies into a 12-week program and
having them compete against each other
or
every we we we choose the amount of
companies that we can take on based on
giving them all a lot of individual
attention and i think our founders
feel that um and so we enjoy having that
comment we actually welcome that and
then it's just really a conversation
about mutual respect
so they need to understand that the if
they're
so the question you're asking is a
completely fair one the
36k the reality is is that anybody who's
gone through alchemist knows that the
money
a lot of people don't even care about
the 36k so the 36k is supposed to pay
for rent just as a background
in san francisco so our program is six
months you're spending six months in san
francisco
you have a team of two people um you
know it's like 3k to pay for your rent
in san francisco per month
um and then we provide co-working space
and then all your other
expenses are basically handled the
spirit of it is more that you know do
you want alchemist to be a partner with
you during this journey
and then is that something that you put
value on and so that's that's sort of
how we have the conversation
and we do think that there are companies
that are different so some of the
companies are
further along others aren't and then and
then um at the end of the day we want to
come to an agreement where both sides
are content and happy and then we move
forward
it hasn't been an issue actually so we
have um we've been really blessed but i
think it's partly just because we do
spend a lot of time
at the beginning making sure that
everybody feels comfortable and then
moving forward i don't know
i just don't even negotiate anymore i
just tell people like listen if
if you're in this zone for the launch
accelerator we're putting in 100k for
six percent
if you think that 100k bought us three
percent two percent one percent four
percent you can calculate it and then
the rest you just have to
decide hey if we paid for three points
at 100k
and do we make the company more than
three percent more valuable after
you get through the accelerator and then
you just have to answer that question
and then some people are super
evaluation sensitive
and if they are super valuation
sensitive it's very simple like you
should just go for max you know
evaluation at all times right go go find
the dentists and
ask them to do a party round i mean i
literally just tell people that like
if you really want to go for max
valuation just get 20 dentists to give
you 50k each
they won't even read the documents yeah
i think that's a good way i think that's
i think you're
that's a good philosophical way of
approaching it yeah and i think what
you're saying is right so the roi
is you know if you have to think about
you know do does it pay for itself
here's how you calculate it
and i think the way what you're getting
at which is the heart of it is that look
you know it's at some level the accuracy
of the valuation is not
the really important thing it's really
about do you want to do this partnership
and then move forward
and i think you know you i think also
you have a fantastic platform and so you
can
just say you know this is the deal and
then go forward we i think we
the reason i stopped negotiation is just
because i felt like it would open up
me to having issues around
fairness with other founders right now
it's just like ugh you know what if like
one founder got a slightly better deal
the other one feels bad you know and
but i understand also i i mean both ways
it cuts both ways because i
we were thinking well let's just pick a
revenue number if you have
50k a month in revenue you get this deal
but then you're like well wait a second
it was 50k and consulting revenue and
another person's got
marketplace revenue is it the take rate
is it the gmv
like how are we gonna actually calculate
this and then it gets even more
complicated
and it's such a small amount of equity
and the and the hit rate is so low
for accelerators like ours like
yeah i'm guessing you're you're
anticipating
90 of your returns are going to come
from how many companies
out of the 300 in your mind what is your
power like 30 so 30 will be 90 right
and then 80 of the returns will be how
many companies
so 90 of the returns come from 10 80
come from the top
three i mean i would say the top the top
of the top 10 the top at the top
you know three percent